[音楽]
[拍手]
皆さんこんにちは僕は大学院生の西山和弘
と言います本日はこんな大きな場をいいて
めちゃめちゃ緊張してるんですが頑張り
たいと思いますのでよろしくお願いし
ますまず初めに皆さんにお聞きしたいこと
がありますそれ
は自分らしく見られる場所や機はどれだけ
ありますかということ
です人によってはこの質問を受けて家庭を
思い浮かべたり職場を思い浮かべたり
もしくはまだ学生の方は学校を
思い浮かべるかもしれませ
ん今日僕は皆さんにお伝えしたいと思って
いるのはもしもあんまり自分らしくい
られる場所や機会がないなって思う方がい
たらそれを地域の中で探してみませんかと
いうことを伝えたいと思ってます地域の中
には自分らしくいられる場所や機械が
たくさん眠っていると僕は信じています
なぜかと言うと僕自身もある地域でそう
いう場所や機会をたくさん見つけることが
できたから
ですその場所は名古屋市北区にある大園と
いう場所
です僕は今大園にある商店街の真ん中で
仲間たちと一緒にシェアハウスをしながら
地域づりの活動をしています
ちなみにシェアハウスはこの赤丸で囲って
ある場所で商店街からってもう手を触れる
ような距離にあるそんなシェアハウス
です僕は元々大園に住んでいたわけでも
何かゆりがあるわけでもありません僕が
大園であったのは大学に入学した直後の
ことでし
た入学した端に知り合いの方から突然
こんなラインが届いたんですいや名城大学
ニューヨクさてねおめでとうちょっと
面白い地域あるから来てくれないかな何か
と思えばいくえ何かと思ってその方の職場
に行ったら僕は5時間ぐらい捕まえられ
ましてえ動画やパワーポイントを使って
大園地域の魅力や面白さを伝えてもらい
まし
たそれにこう引っ張られる形でですね僕は
大園に足を運んでいくようになり
ます例えば大園のお祭りの反正界というな
のを打ち上げに参加させてもらったり僕は
料理は全然できないんですけど
コミュニティカフェでを教えてもらったり
そんなことをしながら僕は大園にどんどん
関わっていくようになるん
ですそしてそんな中大園の夏に開催される
七夕祭りというお祭りに向けてお祭りを
盛り上げる企画を考えるワークショップに
僕は参加するようになり
ますそのワークショップでは僕と同じ大学
生であったりそして地域の方ともどんどん
仲良くなっていきながら熱中して企画を
作ってきましたあの柄にもないんですけど
猫耳つけてるのが僕ですそんな耳つけ
ちゃうぐらいには本当に楽しかったのを今
でも覚えてますで七夕祭りが終わって無事
企画が終わったその当日その一緒に企画を
作ってくれたメンバーの繋がりが終わるの
がなんか嫌だった僕はそこで今度大学祭が
あるんだけど一緒に大園の名物やご通知
キャラクターをコラボさせる企画作ってみ
ないそんなことをメンバーに持ちかけて
ましたメンバー2つ返事でOKをしてくれ
てすごい嬉しかったのを今でも覚えてい
ます
振り返るとそれから僕と大園地域の物語は
始まった気がし
ます僕はこの入学してからの半年間で
馴染みの場所や西和君て呼んでくれるお
世話やきな地域の方そして一緒に活動して
くれる仲間とこの大園で出会うことができ
たんです自分らしくいられる場所や機会に
この大園で出会うことができまし
た僕はその後大園で仲間たちとと一緒に
地域作りの策を立ち上げたりしながらここ
で活動するようになっていき
ますただ地域づり活動って楽しいことだけ
ではないんですやっぱりこういう地域にし
ていきたいああいう地域にしていきたい
そんな思いを皆さんでまとめて一歩
踏み出していくってのはすごい難しいこと
です僕はそれを痛感したのは大園商店街の
活性化を目指す会議隊が出来上がっできて
その会議隊の参あの活動に参加してる時に
それを感じますまし
たその会議隊はあるコンサルタントが支援
をしていましたそのコンサルタントは全国
のいろんなところで実績を持っていて自信
を持ってその会議を進められていきました
こんなことが商店外の活性化のためには
必要だってことであったりこういう役割
必要だよねっていうことでどんどん役割
分担が進んでいったんです僕はそのやり方
に強引さを感じてまし
たそんなある日事件が起こったんです
その会議隊の事務局になった方は自分がい
ないところで事務局をえ任せられてそれで
仕方なく引き受けられていましたその会議
が始まった時にその事務局になった方は
なんで私がこのタスクをやらないといけ
ないんですかってコンサルに聞いたんです
そしたらそのコンサルタントはいや事務局
だから当たり前じゃないですかそんな言わ
れ方したんです
ねそしてその後少し事務局とそのコンサル
の方が行論になって最終的にその
コンサルタントの方
がいやもうじゃあやる気ないんですねいい
ですよもうこの会議から離れて
くださいわかりましたじゃあこれでもう僕
は失礼します
ね記憶ではそんなやり取りを経てその事務
局になった方が会議室から静かに退出され
たことを覚えてい
ますその事務局になった方は僕を大につげ
てくれた方で僕は大子でずっとお世話に
なってきた方でしたそして僕よりも僕
なんかよりもずっとずっと長く大子に
関わられていて地域への思い入れもすごい
ある方でしただから僕はその出来事があっ
た時になんでコンサルタントがこんなこと
を決めるんだろう悔しかったですし生撮り
を感じまし
たそしてその会議隊隊はコンサルが支援し
てる間多くの方が離れていくようになるん
です僕は当時商店街の活性化の必要性は
感じていためにその活動を続けまし
たただ
度々なんで自分はこんなにもう地域活性化
のために頑張ってるんだっけそんな風に
思うこともありまし
た当時の僕は何を目指して地域に関わるか
がとてもあやふやしてたん
ですそんな苦い体験も経て僕は地域作りに
おいて大切にしたいことに気づきまし
たそれは人を大切にする地域づりという
考え方
ですここで言う人には自分も含まれ自分や
誰かの思いや存在を大切にしていくそして
地域作りを行っていくそういう考え方
ですこの言葉を聞いていや当たり前
でしょって思う方だったりいや耳障りの
いい言葉だなって思う方もいるかもしれ
ませんけど僕は地域づりにおいて地域活性
化のためにっていうことで献身的になって
しまってその自分の存在とか誰かの存在が
ないがしろになってしまうこと度々あると
思ってい
ますそしてそういう関わり方いけないこと
だとは全然思ってないですそういうこと
しかそういう関わり方しかからしか始まら
ないこともあるとは分かっていますただ
それでは生き切れしてしまって僕は続か
ないと思っているのでこの人を大切にする
地域づりその考え方を僕は持っていたいと
思いまし
ただから僕は今自分らしい地域との関わり
を育むということを活動の中心に置いてい
ますここで言う自分らしい地域との関わり
を育むということは大きく分けて2つの
ことをやっていて自分らしい地域との
関わりを作るきっかけを生み出していく
そんなこととその関わりの中から主人公と
なる機会を生み出していくその2つの
取り組みを僕はしていますこれは誰かの
思いや存在を地域の人とか出来事につげて
いそんな取り組み
ですきっかけを作り出す取り組みの一例は
オープンな会議の場作りです僕は今大園
待て会議という地域づり団体の事務局をし
ていますそのえ会議隊は毎月1回大園の
地域づりに関心がある方であれば誰でも
参加できる会議の場を開いてるん
ですそなのでその会議の場には商店街の方
だけでなくてその地元の方まえそこ辺に
住まれている方ももちろんいるんですけど
大学生若者やったりあと初めて大子に来る
ような方も多くいらっしゃいますそんな
ごちゃごちゃ混ぜな会議
です僕はその会議の進行をシェアハウスの
仲間と一緒にしていてここの会議の場から
この関わりを生み出すきっかけこの1歩目
にしていくんだっていうことを大切にして
この会議を開いてい
ますそんなことをしていたらこんな景は見
られるようになったんですよく見て
いただくとこちらのテーブルには商店街の
方いらっしゃると同時に大学生の方が同じ
テーブルについてるんですねで隣の
テーブル見ると地域のおさんがいてその隣
にまた大学生がいて書店主さんがいて
みんながこうやって同じ縁になってこの
大園の地域づりについて言葉を交わして
いるんです熱心に議論を交わしてるんです
こんな光景は僕なかなか見られなかったと
思ってます今
までそしてもう1つの取り組み自分らしい
地域との先に主人公を生み出していく機会
を作るそんな取り組みは大学生向けの路上
空間活用方法検討ワークショップという
ワークショップで行ってい
ます大園の商店街は広い路上空間があり
ましてその広い路上空間を生かして
チャレンジできる場を作りたいとか憩いの
場所を作りたいって思いを商店街の方持っ
てたん
です僕はこのワークショップを企画して
いく時にその商店街の方の思いにただ
答えるのではなくそこに自分の求めている
こと大学生が求めていることを
重ね合わせる形で取り組みを生み出して
いけないかと考えたん
ですなのでこのワークショップでは大学生
1人1人のライフヒストリーを丁寧に
振り返って対話をしながら求めていること
を見出す時間を設けましたそしてその求め
ていることを重ね合ったこの赤い星の部分
それを地域がの方も喜ぶ形で実現させて
いこうそんな形でこのワークショップを
進めていったんですそしたらこの
ワークショップこんな社会実験を生み出す
ことができましたというか生まれていまし
たこれはまず公園のようにいろんな人は
交流できるスペースを作る大園ストリート
パークという取り組みそしてもう1つが
ストリートが楽しくなる体験スペースを
作るストリートピアノア初動体験という
取り組みそして自分なりに一歩を踏み出す
チャレンジをストリートでカクテル作り
体験こんな3つの社会実験が気づいたら
生まれていましたこの社会実験は企画をし
てくれた大学生だけじゃなくて参加して
くれたこのこたに入ってるこの子もそして
この子たちのように参加してくれた子たち
にとっても主人公になる機会が生まれたん
じゃないかなと思うそんな取り組みになり
まし
たここまで自分らしい地域との関わりその
を育むことについてお話をしてきました
ただここまでの話で自分らしい地域との
関りを生まれた結果何が生まれるんだろう
とかそれどんな意味があるんだろうって
まだピンと来てない方もいるかもしれませ
んそこで最後に大の中で自分らしい地域と
の関わりが生まれた結果人生が変わって
しまったある友人の話をしたいと思い
ます彼はカッキーと言いますカッキーは僕
と同級生で一緒に街づくりサークルでも
活動してきた仲間
ですカッキーは大学を卒業した後就職活動
に失敗してしまって残念ながら振りたに
なってしまうんですでその時にカッキーと
僕とえ数人の仲間でシアハウスをしていく
ことになるんですがその時にカッキーは
自分
なんかそんな形でいつもどこか劣等感を
感じているように僕からは見えまし
たそんな時に商店街の方とこんな話をして
いまし
た商店街の中にはなんかフラット行ける
ような場所であったりその商店街の方同士
がこうやって喋るような場所ってあんま
ないよねそういう場所できたらいいよね
そんなことを商店街の方と話してたんです
僕はその話をカキにしまし
たなぜかと言うとカキの卒業論文はサード
プレイスという居場所に関することであっ
たくらいかきは居場所や居場所作りに関心
があることは知っていたからですなんで
カッキーに大園で居場所作りしてみない
そんな声かけしてみまし
たそしたら気づくとまカッキーも最初興味
持ってくれてただいやできるかなって言っ
てたんですけど4なよなシアハウスで言葉
をかわしているうちに気づけばチラシが
出来上がってしまってあもうこれやるしか
ないねそんな風になっていまし
たそのカッキーは商店街の方やシェア
ハウスの仲間たちの協力も終えながらから
この大園の秋店舗でコミュニティカフェを
することになり
ます気づくとカッキーは大園の中で店長に
なっていたん
です店長になったカキはその後地域づり
団体の会議にも参加をするようになり
ますその会議の中で広報士を作成していき
たいよねって話が出ていたん
ですだけどその広報士誰が作成していくっ
てことで当時すごく困ってましたそんな時
にまたに声がかかったんですいやカキお金
もつくしちょっとこれ候補作ってみない
いやデザインけどしたことないしお金も
つくけどつくならなおさら不安だなそんな
やり取りをしていましたそしたら横にいた
地域の方がこんな声をかけてくれたん
です商店街の関係性の中であれば私も含め
てサポートしてあげられるしそれにこの
大園だったら失敗しても大丈夫だよ
そんな力強い声をかけてもらいまし
たそのカッキーはその言葉に後押しをされ
てこの大園地域で広報士を作成していく
ようになります店長になった各期次にです
ね
あ編集長になったん
ですカキはその1年間で店長になって編集
長になっていたん
です最近カキをしる周りの友人からは
なんか最近器変わったねてよくそうです
そしてあのこのトークが始まる前にカキに
今どんな感じって聞いてみたんですそし
たらかきはこんな言葉を返してくれました
さっき一瞬出ました
けど真ができていい意味で人生を1度諦め
て病んでも闇にならないっていうか曲がら
ないわけではないけどなんとかなる
しなやかさみたいなのができてどうしよう
もない不安からある程度自分がしっかり
できるようになったというか
というのは思うか
なこの言葉書きを知らない方にとっては
パっと見に何言ってるんだろうって思わ
れるかもしれないですけどカキを知る自分
からはとても何を伝えたいか伝わってきた
気がします1年前フリターになって人生を
悲観していたカッキーは大園で自分の真を
見つけて自分を大切で大切にできるように
なっていっ
て変わっ行ったっていうことが僕は伝わっ
てきまし
たこの1年間で店長になって編集長になっ
たこのカッキーの姿を見て僕はカッキーが
主人公の物語を見てるようだなそんな思い
に抱くようになりまし
た今日皆さんにお伝えしたかったことは
もしも自分
らしい自分らしくいられる場所や機会が
ないなって思う方がいたらの中でそれを
探していませんかということでし
たもしも今日の話を聞いて何か感じるもの
があった
方地域に一歩踏み出してあなたも地域で
生まれる物語の主人公になっていませんか
もしかしたらあなたが次の第2第3のカキ
かもしれませ
んこれで僕の話を終わりたいと思います
今日はありがとうございました